good morning believe nation today's
message is embrace failure over you
Arianna Huffington embrace failure to
remember what my mom used to say to me
which is that failure is not the
opposite of success it's a stepping
stone to success my second book which I
wrote when I was 27 and was rejected by
36 publishers I remember how devastating
that felt partly because it seemed like
I had picked their own career and I
really should do something else and
partly because I had run out of money
and i was living in london at the time
and i remember walking down some james's
street and seeing barclays bank and
walking in and asking to see the manager
and asking for a loan which he gave me
even though i had no assets and it
changed my life because it made it
possible for me to hold everything
together until finally i got an
acceptance but also it made me realize
that so often in life and it's a little
bit like in fairy tales when the hero or
the heroine are lost in a dark forest
and helpful animals appear out of
nowhere to help them find their way well
this bank manager was a kind of helpful
animal so there are a lot of helpful
animals disguised as human beings bank
managers or whatever who helped us along
the way so approaching life with a
certain amount of trust and willingness
to take risks is key to succeeding this
is such an important message for
entrepreneurs because for some reason
for some reason in this society we have
deemed failure to be failure to be evil
fair to be bad baby to be we're so
judged on something that we're afraid to
go and do something again where the
reality is you fail your way to success
right you will fail your way to success
anything that you tried the first time
failed that right you tried to tie your
shoelaces you feel you tried to get up
and walk for the first time you fail you
tried to use chopsticks you failed and
we have this expectation that as soon as
you start in business you're going to be
successful what did that come from
you're going to fail so many times but
failure is normal failure is good daily
teaches you how not to do something
gives you some experience to do it
better the next time and I think the
person the entrepreneur who tries to
start a business and all they do is try
to avoid failure then they're playing
it's so safe that they're not taking any
kind of risk and part of being an
entrepreneur is you're taking some risk
you're doing something different you're
doing something that stretches your
comfort zone that's the exciting stuff
that's where the juice is man and so I
find a lot of entrepreneurs they start a
business and it doesn't work out and
then they they fall back on well I'm not
maybe I'm not insisting entrepreneur I'm
not meant to be an entrepreneur yeah I
tried it once and it didn't work out
that's not how you're going to have
success right that's that's that's just
one learning curve if you look at any
successful entrepreneur this is a good
practice and good experiences where
adopted my mindset study success look at
the famous entrepreneurs look at how
they got started there was insane
failure from the beginning they failed
they failed they bailed the Veil the
veil to fail and then it became
successful and that's the secret and now
it's not doing the same thing over and
over and over again so you keep failing
at the same thing right you learned you
get better and the next time hopefully
you won't fail even worse are the people
who failed once and then they bring you
down because they fail you can't have
success right those are the little main
we all have the little man in our lives
too don't be surrounded by them don't be
that person yourself and the next time
that you fail at something just see it
as feedback see it as a way to learn and
develop as long as you are learning from
it then it's not really failure because
you've grown
you do something brighter the next time
so the question that a today is what are
you failing at right now leave in the
comments below i'm going to join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot I've been
stressing